[Musique]
bienvenue dans Europe etd émission
présentée depuis Strasbourg nous sommes
ici à deux pas de l'hémicycle dans ce
que l'on appelle la salle de lecture ici
la règle c'est silence absolu et dans la
partie magazine de cette émission nous
aborderons la question du multilinguisme
qui est extrêmement sensible ici au
Parlement tien et d'abord le tour de
l'actualité
[Musique]
européenne on le croyait validé pourtant
le plan d'aide européen fait toujours
débat une nouvelle réunion à Bruxelles
entre les ministres des Finances de
l'Eurogroup devait tenter d'enrayer la
chute de l'euro au plus bas depuis 4 ans
mais les discussions se sont crispées
sur les modalités de déblocage des 750
milliards d'euros du plan de sauvetage
le ton serait même monté d'un cran entre
la France et l'Allemagne dans le même
temps le quotidien Paï affirme que
Nicolas Sarkozi aurait menacé de quitter
la zone euro pour forcer la main
d'Angela Merkel toujours réticante à
l'égard de ce plan
d'aide un plan d'aide qui conduit la
majeure partie des pays de la zone euro
à mettre en œuvre des coupes drastiques
dans leur budget en France François
Fillon annonce un gel des dépenses de
l'État pour les 3 ans à venir un plan de
rigueur qui ne dit pas son nom selon
l'opposition en Espagne José Luis
sappatero a annoncé une baisse de 5 % du
salaire des fonctionnaires provocquant
la colère des syndicats au Portugal on
se prépare à une hausse de 1 point de la
TVA et de 1 à 1,5 % de l'impôt sur le
revenu enfin en Italie le gouvernement
pourrait augmenter prochainement les
impôts locaux après avoir gelé les
salaires des
[Musique]
fonctionnaires les Estoniens
seraient-ils sur le point de changer de
monnaie alors que la zone euro traverse
la pire crise de son histoire la
Commission européenne a donné son feu
vert à l'Estonie pour son entrée dans
l'euro dès l'année prochaine pour procès
manuel Barosso c'est un signe de
confiance dans l'avenir l'Estonie serait
le 17e pays à entrer dans
[Musique]
l'Eurogroupe la crise économique
pourrait ouvrir une nouvelle ère dans
les relations tendues entre la Grèce et
la Turquie en conflit larvé depuis des
décennies les Grecs et les Turques se
taquinent souvent militairement
historique le Premier ministre turc RP
Tayip Erdogan s'est rendu à Athènes pour
signer une vingtaine d'accords
bilatéraux et mettre en place un Conseil
supérieur de opération contrainte à un
plan de rigueur sans précédent la grèe a
par ailleurs annoncé une réduction de
ses dépenses militaires aujourd'hui la
Grèce dépense tous les ans trois fois
plus que ses voisins européens pour
assurer sa
défense voilà pour ce tour d'Europe et
nous sommes toujours à Strasbourg dans
le grand bâtiment de verre du Parlement
européen nous sommes avec un député
européen socialiste français bonjourour
limooc donc vous avez vous êtes par
ailleurs économiste actualité européenne
très économique l'Europe qui tente
désespérément de sauver sa monnaie
commune mais la la mise en route de ce
plan de 750 milliards d'euros traîne
est-ce que pour vous l'Europe n'a pas
tiré toutes les leçons de la crise
grecque B le la mise en œuvre du plan a
traîné parce que l'Allemagne a été
extrêmement hésitante dans cette affaire
et si on veut comprendre l'état des
débats aujourd'hui il faut naturellement
remonter à 1914 les Allemands ne veulent
plus payer depuis cette date et les
Allemands sont obsédés par
l'hyperinflation qui qui les a touché à
cette époque là d'où les les deux tabous
qui ont longtemps perduré en Europe qui
ont été transgressés maintenant avec le
plan de sauvetage à la GR mais pour vous
l'Allemagne est responsable de cette
situation on peut comprendre l'Allemagne
mais si vous voulez il y a deux tabous
auquels il tient enfin il tenait qui
était premièrement le fait de d'éviter
de de de de trop payer dans le cadre de
mécanisme de solidarité qui qui les
aurait engagé puis le deuxème àabou
c'était le le fait que la banque
centrale elle-même finance un certain
nombre de dépenses parce que euh les
Allemands considè généralement que la
création monétaire est inflationniste et
comme ils veulent éviter l'épisode des
années 20 ils ont longtemps été attachés
au fait que la la banque centrale dans
ses statuts ne ne ne finance pas les les
les budgets publics et là deux tabous
ont été levés le le premier c'est qu'on
a créé un fond de stabilisation et un
fond de soutien financé par l'empruntite
comment F vous vous en félicitez oui
absolument euh on a levé ces deux tabous
qui qui sont des des des pas en avant
euh en direction d'une véritable
gouvernance économique de la zone euro
on peut pour la première fois financer
des dépenses communautaires par
l'emprunt alors que c'était interdit
pour le moment jusqu'àors pardon dans
les textes européens et puis le le la
deuxième avancée c'est que la banque
centrale peut désormais euh financer les
dettes souveraines ce qui permet aux
États euh de s'affranchir de de la
pression des marchés financiers lorsque
ces derniers exige des primes de risque
inconsidéré avec des taux d'intérêt trop
élevés il faire marcher la planche
habillé si si mais ça permet si vous
voulez et pour vous ce cela n'est pas
choquant bah aujourd'hui la situation
n'est pas celle des années 20 justement
il n'y a aucune pression inflationniste
créer de la monnaie aujourd'hui n'est
pas de nature à relancer l'inflation
parce que l'économie est en sous-emploi
il y a 20 millions de chômeurs en Europe
les capacités de production sont
sous-utilisées si vous relancez la
demande par la création monétaire en
finançant notamment les plans de R
bon ce qu'on attend encore ça n'a pas
d'effet inflationniste aujourd'hui
normalement alors l'euro baisse sa
valeur ne cesse de de tomber est-ce que
pour vous on s'inquiète de cette baisse
de l'euro en même temps est-ce que ça n'
permet pas de doper les exportations
européennes donc de redonner un un
ballon
d'oxygène à l'Europe al moi je ne suis
pas inquiet de la baisse de l'euro ce
sont les Américains qui s'en inquiètent
c'est la raison pour laquelle Barack
Obama téléphone ang Merkel car la la
baisse de l'euro naturellement favorise
nos exportations au détriment du
commerce extérieur américain lorsque
nous exportons vers les États-Unis donc
vous plaidez pour une dépréciation de
l'euro pour redonner un peu d'air aux
économies européennes il y a pas si
longtemps vaer regist carestin et c que
le le le cours d'équilibre c'était 1 €o
égal un dollar donc on on en est pas
encore là si vous voulez donc l'euro est
sans doute encore un petit peu
surévaluer mais il y il y a un deuxième
problème en dehors de ça c'est que le
commerce extérieur de la plupart des
pays membres se fait à l'intérieur de
zone euro et même si l'euro se
dépréciait suffisamment ça ne réglerait
en aucun cas le problème des Espagnols
des Grecs et des Italiens qui souffr
aujourd'hui d'un commerce extérieur
déficitaire vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne et
vraisemblablement il faudrait des
mécanismes de solidarité beaucoup plus
poussé que ceux qui ont été mis en œuvre
la semaine dernière si on veut que ces
pays rattrapent le niveau de
développement de l'Allemagne pour
l'instant l'Europe a encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire elle n'est quand même pas
forcément très compétitive au sein du du
jeu mondial
oh l'Allemagne est compétitive les
autres pays sont un peu moins mais le
vrai débat c'est à l'intérieur de la
zone euro il y a des déséquilibres à
l'intérieur de la zone euro entre les
pays du Nord et les pays du Sud et toute
la question est de savoir comment on
aide les pays du Sud à converger en leur
r donnant les moyens il y a une autre
solution pour renforcer la la
gouvernance européenne était proposé par
la Commission européenne une une
proposition qui a fait beaucoup de de
bruit euh puisque Bruxelles souhaite
avoir un droit de regard sur les budgets
nationaux éléments essentiel de la
souveraineté nationale explication avec
Florence
[Musique]
Maurice la commission aura-t-elle
bientôt un droit de regard sur les
budgets des États européens la semaine
dernière José Manuel Baroso a en tout
cas ouvert une brèche il souhaite que
les projets de loi de finances soi
examiné par Bruxelles avant même leur
adoption par les parlements nationaux un
cont ô qui aurait lieu chaque année à
partir de
2011 la politique économique d'un pays
n'est pas simplement une politique
nationale la politique économique de nos
étatsmembres c'est une affaire aussi
européenne s'ils sont membres de la zone
euro c'est absolument clair c'est une
question d'intérêt commun objectif
remettre en celle le pacte de stabilité
dont les critères sont de moins en moins
respecté mais la proposition a soulevé
un to en particulier en France le par c
que Bruxelles n'empiète sur sa
souveraineté nationale le président de
l'Eurogroupe Jean-Claude Junker se veut
pourtant rassurant pour lui c'est
l'occasion d'améliorer la concertation
entre les États bref de mettre en place
un début de gouvernement économique en
Europe le débat ne fait donc que
commencer le président du Conseil a
lancé un groupe de travail avec les
ministres des Finances pour plancher sur
la question il rendra ses conclusions en
octobre NOOC est-ce que Bruxelles a
raison de se mêler des budgets nationaux
est-ce que c'est une bonne proposition
pour vous alors nous autres socialistes
sommes des fédéralistes convaincus donc
nous pensons qu'il faut une meilleure
coordination des politiques budgétaires
dans un cadre fédéral et de ce point de
vue-là il peut être opportun de euh
faire en sorte que les politique
budgétaire soit adapté à la conjoncture
dans tous les pays malheureusement la la
proposition de la Commission euh est une
proposition qui arrive comme
contrepartie au plan de sauvetage et qui
impose des plans de
rigueur ce que ce que la Commission a
essayé de faire ici c'est de de de
renforcer son rôle de gendarme euh pour
que les plans de rigueur qui me
paraissent
être mal venus inapproprié et inutile
aujourd'hui dans un contexte où on n'est
pas sorti de la crise donc ce que veut
faire la commission c'est c'est de
renforcer son pouvoir de contrôle et
durcir le PACT de stabilité ce qui est
une erreur ce qu'on aurait dû faire au
contraire c'est certes de de vouloir
coordonner les politiques budgétaires
mais de mettre dans le jeu et les
parlements nationaux et le Parlement
européen et de définir les les critères
qui permettent de coordonner les
politiques budgétaires pour soutenir la
croissance en période de ralentissement
comme aujourd'hui au lieu d'appliquer
des plans comment concrètement comment
fait-on dans un tel contexte
avec de tel déficit qui qui réduisent
toutes les marges de manœuvre comment
fait-on pour donner un peu d'air à
l'économie qu'est-ce que vous vous
préconisez en tant que député socialiste
et en tant qu'économiste bah il faut
dédramatiser le discours sur la dette
excessive tous les macro-économistes
vous expliqueront qu'avant la crise ce
que l'on appelle les déficits
structurels en Europe sont proches de
l'équilibre c'est-à-dire hors variation
des recettes fiscales liées au aux
fluctuations de la conjoncture la
dégradation des comptes courants est
essentiellement d à la crise au fait
qu'on que que que la croissance a chuté
qu'on a pris des mesures de sauvetage
des banques et que par ailleurs on a
baissé des impôts ce qui a tari les
recettes fiscales par ailleurs bon donc
il y a tout ça et la question
aujourd'hui est de savoir si on veut
rentrer dans les clous c'està réduire
les déficits est-ce qu'on dans CL du
PACT de stabilité qui impose la maîtrise
des déficits public c'est ça que vous
dites oui alors si on veut rentrer dans
les clous est-ce que la bonne solution
c'est des plans de rigueur qui
manifestement vont casser la croissance
et moins de croissance et moins de
fiscale et c'est des déficiites qui vont
continuer à se creuser donc ou alors
l'autre solution ça serait de dire on
suspend temporairement le PACT de
stabilité absolument c'est ce que pou
rasmusen également a proposé lorsqu'il a
il a demandé un moratoire de 2 ans du
PACT pour laisser redémarrer les
économies pour que les économies
puissent emprunter engager des des
mesures de relance et à ce moment-là
lorsque la croissance est revenue elle
induit des recettes fiscales qui permet
qui permettent de de réduire les
déficits merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité limagoc on vous laisse se
retourner dans l'hémicycle on rejoint
tout de suite Olivier Picard et ses
invités qui nous parlent du
multilinguisme en Europe
oui Katia la question du multilinguisme
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible ici
au Parlement européen alors pour en
parler Nora Amadi Florence Maurice et
Romain Dusseau nous ont emmené dans les
coulisses de cette extraordinaire
[Musique]
usine aujourd'hui à Strasbourg s jour de
plainère le Parlement européen fourmille
les 736 députés viennent siéger pour
voter mais le pic d'activité c'est aussi
pour les 1000 interprètes qui
travaillent dans les 23 langues
officielles de l'Union
européenne Laurent Bernard a 62 ans il
est français il traduit depuis
l'allemand l'anglais l'italien et
l'arabe vers le français cela fait 32
ans qu'il officie au Parlement européen
est confronté pour des auditions en
particulier à des sujets qui sont tout
nouveaux au moment de la crise de la
vache folle on a utiliser des mots danss
dans nos auditions ici au Parlement que
on ne trouvait même pas dans les
journaux puisque le thème était nouveau
et donc les interprète participent à la
comment presque à la création de quelque
chose et pour éviter les surprises il
passe plusieurs heures à se documenter
son but maîtriser ses sujets sur le bout
des doigts la préparation factuelle
c'est celle-ci c'est la préparation
ponctuelle mais il est évident qu'un
interprète ne peut pas se contenter de
cela et que sa préparation réelle ce
sera tout ce qu'il aura fait par aard
c'està-dire tout ce que aura accumulé au
cours de sa vie ce sera de la
préparation de réunion à l'autre bout du
Parlement l'autre grand chantier la
traduction des documents direction
l'imprimerie à cette heure les machines
tournent à plein régimees textes sont
une base de travail pour les députés les
assistants ou les interprètes et cela
représente des tonnes de papiers le
volume total de l'imprimerie contenu des
fluctuations mensuelles tourne autour de
100 millions de pages par an depuis
l'élargissement en 2004 chaque langue
doit être traduite dans les 22 autres
soit 506 combinaisons une des
difficultés c'est donc dispose pas de
traducteurs ou de quantités de
traducteurs suffisantes pour aller de
chaque langue vers chaque langue on
utilise le système dit de langu pivot
l'anglais le français l'allemand et
l'espagnol quatre langues pivot quatre
langues relais pour permettre la
traduction par exemple on ne dispose pas
de traducteur d'une langue comme le
finois vers le hongrois et dans ce
cas-là on traduit d'abord du finois vers
par exemple l'anglais et ensuite de
l'anglais vers le
hongroistion une fois l'impression
terminée direction la documentation dans
l'autreile du
Parlement et pour acheminer tous ces
documents il a fallu réaliser de gros
travaux d'aménagement et notamment
creuser un tunnel sous la
[Musique]
rivière sa préparation terminée Laurent
va récupérer l'ordre du jour de la
prochaine séance
voilà monsieur vient de me donner donc
les rapports que je lui ai demandé
traduction interprète cette organisation
à un coup que cela représente un/ers du
budget du Parlement et un/ers de son
personnel le prix a payé pour garantir
l'égalité de traitement à tous les
citoyens européens un droit gravé dans
les traités Doris PAC est présidente de
la commission culture et éducation au
Parlement pour la députée allemande
cette dépense est
indispensable 23 langues et plus
prochainement plus c'estj quelque chose
qui est vraiment luxurieux mais il faut
le garder parce que c'est notre
tradition notre culture et les collègues
les Français ou les Allemands ou les
Polonais ne se reconnaisserent plus plus
comme comme membre de cette institution
si cette institution ne parle pas leur
langue je pense l'argent pour
l'interprétation est bien bien dépenser
parce que c'est mieux de parler avec
avec
re entre nous que de faire de la guerre
dans une Europe à 27 à l'heure où la
Croatie la Turquie et la Macédoine sont
candidates à l'Union certains députés
militent même pour la reconnaissance des
langues régionales comme le catalan le
Corse ou le
[Musique]
russe avec nous aujourd'hui Miguel enrel
Martinez vous êtes l'un des 14
vice-présidents du Parlement vous êtes
polyglote et vous êtes en charge dans
cette maison du multilinguisme alors on
vient de le voir dans le reportage 23
langues 1000 interprètes 506
combinaisons il y a des députés qui dans
la maison trouvent que ça coûte trop
cher alors est-ce qu'il faut revenir
tout simplement à quatre langues pivot
comme certains le
proposent d'abord je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'affirmation de ce que ce
soit cher c'est très bon marché
mais c'est un principe essentiel de la
démocratie donc même si ça coûtait un
petit peu plus ce serait déjà très bon
marché quand même vous savez le principe
essentiel c'est que nos citoyens nos
concitoyens nos concitoyennes pour nous
élir pour nous élire en tant que leur
représentant
euh ils ne peuvent pas dépendre de ce
qu'on connaisse des langues ou qu'on nen
connaisse pas nous on est ici parce
qu'on a la confiance oui de nos peuples
respectifs et la confiance se mesure sur
d'autres éléments que le fait de parler
le Léon le Slovène ou l'anglais mais
est-ce que la simplification de l'Europe
n'a pas pour prix justement l'abandon
d'une certaine souveraineté sur sa
propre langue ah non non non non est-ce
qu'on peut pas sacrifier un peu de sa
langue pour la la lisibilité de l'Europe
non non je vous dis moi moi des citoyens
de ma province quand ils vont me quand
ils me votent pour venir ici ils me
votent pas parce que je m'exprime en
français ils s'en foutent que je que je
sache parler le français ou l'anglais ou
l'allemand ça ça ne les avance en rien
ils savent qui je suis ils savent que je
défendrai et même si je ne parle pas un
mot parce que je ne parle jamais avec
eux en anglais ni en enseigner en
allemand quand à dire que c'est très
cher il faut savoir de quoi on parle
vous savez le budget de toute l'Union
européenne pas que le Parlement le
Parlement c'est un c'est un morceau le
Parlement le Conseil la Commission la
Cour des comptes la la la Cour de
justice tout ça cela représente par
citoyen européen le prix d'un café par
an d'accord al moi je trouve que c'est
ridiculement bon marché surtout si si si
l'on paye avec cela ce principe
fondamental de la démocratie qui
consiste à ce qu'ici chacun peut parler
dans sa langue peut tout dire dans sa
langue et peut surtout tout écouter dans
sa langue parce que je me demande
comment j'écouterais le le Slovaque ou
l'Irlandais ou le maltais comment je
l'écoutera s'il me parlait dans sa
langue ou ou s'il était obligé de
s'exprimer dans une langue étrangère
qu'il ne nuance pas mais au-delà au-delà
du principe dans le fonctionnement
l'anglais est beaucoup utilisé ici dans
dans la maison est-ce qu'il y a pas
finalement une une poussée insidieuse de
l'anglais derrière effectivement le très
beau principe du multilinguisme c'est
écoutez il y a la langue unique la
langue unique traduit la pensée unique
nous savons t t tous les tous les méfets
de ce que la pensée unique a pu
représenter heureusement on dirait
qu'elle est un peu dépassée à l'heure
actuelle donc c'est évident que qui que
que que si l'on ne devait parler qu'une
langue on parla en anglais al parler en
anglais ce qui parlent l'anglais alors
là là écoutez comme moi latin que je
suis et et même si je parle l'anglais et
si je je reconnait l'anglais est une
belle langue tout ce que vous voulez
c'est un c'est un principe à mon ami
fondamental de ne pas accepter à un
moment donné vous savez j'avais proposé
quelque chose d quand on me disait qu'on
ne parle qu'en trois ou quatre langues
j'avais dit moi je serais à la limite
capable d'accepter cela si chacun devait
parler dans une langue qui soit pas la
sienne c'estàd que le Britannique parle
en français que le français parle en
allemand que l'allemand parle là là là
ça nous mettrait sur un pied d'égalité
non de démocratie mais moins d'égalité
alors à l'autre extrême il y a des
députés qui vont carrément plus loin que
vous encore et il y en a un qui vous
pose une question un député vert on
[Musique]
l'écoute monsieur Martinez vous
participez donc au nouvel exécutif à
nouvel présidence du Parlement qui vient
d'être élu et il y a sur la table de ce
Parlement depuis longtemps la la
question de la mise en œuvre d'une
reconnaissance de la langue catalagne et
de la mise en place de dispositifs pour
que les Catalans puissent s'exprimer
dans leur langue évidemment ma question
c'est simplement que comptez-vous faire
prochainement pour que tout cela rentre
en en œuvre et soit
opérationnel pour aller jusqu'au bout de
l'égalité écoutez la langue catalane
m'est cher elle fait partie de de la
culture de mon pays je ne suis pas
catalan moi-même mais mais c'est une
c'est l'une des des quatre langues qui
existent dans mon pays et qui sont
coefficiels dans certains territoires
mais il existe au moins une trentaine de
langues qui ont ce même statut de langue
coofficielle dans certains territoires
des pays actuellement membres de l'Union
européenne la chose serait encore plus
compliqué dans la perspective de deux ou
trois pays qui vont venir nous rejoindre
d'ici
peu on a fait un progrès dans ce sens
que les citoyens qui nous écrivent dans
ces langues officiel notamment dans les
langues cooficielles de l'Espagne euh
dans certains territoires espagnol euh
reçoivent des répones on on on admet des
pétitions des des requêtes et ceter le
le fait de d'introduire ces langues dans
le dans le dans dans le quotidien de
compliquerit la chose d'une façon euh
sérieuse mais vous parle vous parliez
tout à l'heure d'identité vous disiez
les chaque citoyen européen doit se
reconnaître dans sa propre langue
est- qu'il faut pas aller jus bout de la
logique à ce momentlonnaî toutes les
langes régal dans mais non non mais tous
ces gens-là
connaissent leur langue nationale
peuvent s'exprimer dans leur langue
nationale qui est au même titre que le
que leur langue régionale une langue
officielle dans laquelle ils s'expriment
donc c'est pas que ces gens-là ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer ils s'expriment
dans leur langue nationale est-ce que
vous ressentez-vous en en en charge du
multilinguisme ici au Parlement une
pression justement de de de ces
différents territoires ou régions pour
la justement l'introduction de leur
langue ici au Parlement vous savez
certaines régions ont exercé cette
pression etexerce et c'est d'ailleurs
c'est certains de mes camarades qui qui
me donc c'est un sujet qui qui que je
manie tous les jours y compris ces
jours-ci donc parce qu' on pensait ici
nous au cors bien sûr en France russe
basque ENF oui oui oui oui mais donc
c'est je vous dis je vous dis il y a des
il faut connaître bien l'histoire de
l'Europe pour avoir il y a même il y a
même des langues très importantes qui ne
sont pas comme le Russe qui ne sont pas
des langues officielles de de des pays
membres de de l'Union européenne mais
qui peuvent l'être dans certains
territoires ou chez certaines minorités
de certains pays membres donc ça
pourrait nous ammener très loin mais JEI
la question est est de permettre à tout
citoyen de s'exprimer dans sa langue
officielleon sa langue officielle c'est
pour le cas du catalan ou tu c'est
l'espagnol au même titre que le catalan
ou le basque donc donc puisqu'il peut
s'exprimer dans l'une des deux langues
qu'il est censé manier dans son
territoire nous pensons que ça remplit
les conditions nécessaires en ayant
avancé jusqu'à ce qu'ils peuvent
s'exprimer dans ces languesl par écrit
pour toute une série de démarches dans
le contexte du Parlement donc pas de
langue supplémentaire ici 23 on s'arrête
là ah non on s'arrête pas là parce que
le Croat est à la porte et c'est langu
le le le le
Macédonien n'est pas loin le turc et
bien sûr mais le Turc devrait déjà être
langue officielle si la situation de
était une situation normale le
Turc serait une langue officielle déjà
j'envisage moi j'envisage trois langues
de plus je veux bien que le Serbe va
devenir une langue officielle d'ici 10
ans je ne crois pas que l'Islande malgré
la démarche de négociation va aller
jusqu'au bout parce que je mes
informations font que le peuple
islandais ne va pas ratifier euh en
référendum l'entrée dans l'Union
européenne mais enfin mais je moi je ne
peux pas envisager d'aller au-delà de 27
28 langues encore séant jamais n'est-ce
pas bon et Miguel
hangelen Martinez excusez-moi pour ma
prononciation à la française merci
beaucoup c'est le moment de retrouver
notre clin d'œil cette semaine on
s'intéresse à Europavox à clairement
conf férant du 20 au 23 mai 2010 c'est
un festival qui a la particularité de
vouloir mettre en valeur toute la
diversité de la production musicale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
européenne du C Duard de Rayana Auer de
M et coca le canal en canal
dyanfobama à la BR de l' an de Nana et
leur un ninja coup proj du ninjaoup les
photes d'autopsie de tout chour chaque
jour je passe du morbide au futile me
perd dans un deses d'image inutile une
gamine en pile des gobelets en pyramide
je me dis qu'elle est rapide et que mon
temps je dis laapide dans laise on surf
à la dynamite l'AM pour avoir son quart
d'heure de gloire comme dit
[Musique]
la
voilà c'est terminé pour cette émission
nous avons eu beaucoup de plaisir à vous
présenter depuis Strasbourg et la
semaine prochaine retour à Bruxelles
pour un autre numéro d'europedo très
bonne suite de programme sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires